[Music]
and now the meeting of the minds
part two
all right why should i say a thing let's
just get to round two
i want to ask you a question about covet
because you had covid and i my wife you
met my wife i don't know it was like six
years ago uh in mar-a-lago she's still
not gotten vaccinated and i keep talking
to her to get her to get vaccinated and
she hasn't
what would you say to her well first of
all say why is she not doing it does she
have some kind of religious things no
she's skeptical she's skeptical doesn't
trust well she's russian yes she's
scripted that's the end of that exactly
you can't argue with the russians no
you're very smart yeah very hard-headed
yes i think i know your wife a little
bit right yes but she's great and uh let
her do what she wants to do i got
vaccinated and i feel very good i think
we saved millions and millions of people
worldwide you know in 1917 they say
almost 100 million approximately 100
million people died yeah i think we
could have been into that situation
because it was very bad
and now if you're vaccinated at the
other thing it shows that if you do get
sick you don't get sick like they were
before meaning you don't die exactly so
uh i would recommend but i also say that
let her have her freedoms you know the
word freedom right yeah exactly and with
you she needs freedom
she needs a lot of freedom from me i
found
i think i probably have to agree with
that here's a question i bet no one's
ever asked you this i think i might know
the answer how hard is it
being prep being president from a scale
to one to ten
well i had two forms of presidency
number one i had to run the country work
on the world and do things and the other
thing i had to survive yeah the survival
was much tougher because i had fake
mueller people coming after me i had 19
really haters after me i had every form
of law enforcement after me it started
from the day i came down the escalator
it never stops they have every
prosecutor after me they're looking at
deals that i did years and years ago i
forgot about them
it is a disgrace so i had to survive
number one and number two i had to write
really you know i guess i'd put it in a
different order but if you don't survive
you can't do a good job in terms of
running so i had survival and i had
running the country right and i would
say the survival was actually much
tougher running the country somebody
said what was the toughest president a
friend of mine very very successful guy
used to call me don
donny
donald now he said mr president you know
you lose all your friends because you're
president they're all afraid to talk to
you okay
mr president could i ask you one
question
what's the toughest who was the toughest
to deal with was it china could it be
putin in russia what about north korea
kim jong-un
i said well the toughest actually was
the united states dealing with these
maniacs that we have over here with
pelosi and schumer and all of them that
was probably the toughest far tougher
than
a lot of world leaders and
isn't that a shame when you think about
it isn't it a shame well there was a
there's a lot of irration there was an
irrational response to you and i and i i
mean i lost friends when i would defend
you but you also gained friends yeah you
gained friends i i didn't listen to uh
my family members who were voting for
you yeah during the time and i had and i
had friends who were voting for you but
i didn't listen and then when i when i
turned and started listening then i lost
all of my other friends did it bother
you to like see friends that you've had
lose these friends because you became
president and they didn't like what you
were doing or they became emotionally
and irrationally kind of unhinged
trump delusion sure right trump uh
derangement syndrome they they call them
a lot of things but derangement syndrome
seems and there is something like that i
mean it's crazy and why would they do
that we rebuilt the military we took
care of everything we came up whether
you say vaccines or helping people
medically
uh you know right to try where they were
able to try somebody dying yeah and we
have drugs that might work and you
couldn't use them none of that mattered
because they were it was an emotional
response taxes by the way regulations
the largest tax cut in history largest
regulation cut by far in history you
know all records but why why do why do
people respond emotionally to you rather
than rationally it must be my
personality that's what i can think i
mean we did a great job i rebuilt the
military yes all that beautiful stuff
that brand new stuff and you know who
has it now
yeah huh the taliban
i built it for the taliban exactly it
wasn't supposed to happen and now we see
these beautiful perfect brand new rifles
and these guys are carrying two yes and
they're wearing our uniforms i know and
they're flying our helicopters and it's
a disgrace you know what we might have
converted them because it's like
christmas to them yeah well it is
christmas it's christmas they're still
celebrating okay so i told you about
abdul so he's tough and when i first
spoke to him by phone
i said
nice to speak to you by phone abdul and
he goes
you know they're ferocious people right
you know like you go to broadway shows
they fight they like to fight they've
been fighting for about a thousand years
how long broadway by the way i say that
you do
i like it actually
you know it's very interesting and i've
been saying it for a long time
our country
the worst decision ever made was going
into the quicksand which is called the
middle east
two trillion dollars and millions of
lives because i like to count both sides
okay right millions of lives
and the place has been obliterated
and it's more dangerous now if you think
about it
i had them in check i wiped out isis you
know who i took out i took out the
leaders the biggest people bigger than
anybody nobody even believes what i did
and
in a few months it can all be dissipated
yes all right
like i said we're gonna milk this
interview for all it's worth we've got
more of it tomorrow night right here on
gutvald hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else